سياره مهمه جدا الرئيس الامريكي سوفيتون
الى بولندا وايضا الخطوه التي سبقتها بل
توجه الى كييف بالتاكيد التزام الولايات
المتحده بتواجدها في هذه المنطقه من
العالم وايضا التزامها بدعم اوكرانيا لحتى
النهايه الذي استعاده اراضيها كما قال
الرئيس الامريكي وايضا ضمان حمايه وامن
دول شرق الناتو كانت سابقا حتى قبل
الاعلان عن زياره الرئيس الامريكي تطالب
بعده نقاط رئيسيه اهمها هي زياده الوجود
الامريكي في منطقه جناح الشرقي لدول
الناتو خصوصا بعد الحادثه الاخيره التي
حصلت وسقوط صواريخ دفاع جوي داخل الاراضي
البولنديه
لذلك ايضا بولندا وقعت العديد من عقود
الاسلحه مع الجانب الامريكي كونها قدمت
جزء كبير من مخزوناتها للجانب الاوكراني
فاصبح لديها نقص كبير في المخزونات
العسكريه وكانت تطالب الولايات المتحده
بتخزيع تسليم هذه الاسلحه وتوقيع المزيد
من العقود ايضا للخطوات القادمه الخطوه
الثالثه هي ايضا تنسيق
الجهود العسكريه بين الولايات المتحده
بشكل خاص ودموع للجناح الشرقي التي تعتبر
نفسها راس الحربه وفي مواجهه مباشره مع
روسيا كون لديها حدود مباشره مع اوكرانيا
التي تتعرض للغزو الروسي فقمت تسعه ستكون
ايضا من احد المحطات المهمه جدا خلال
زياره الرئيس الامريكي والتي من المتوقع
ان يصدر عنها التعليمات او توضيح للمرحله
القادمه وكيف سوف يكون التواجد الامريكي